[Musique]
vous avez fait beaucoup de prescription
de subutex et derniers mois bah je suis
souvent fait part des usagers série
doctor who parler des toxicomanes
docteur feki papa oui oui des
toxicomanes et méfiez vous parce que
nous sommes prêts à ouvrir une enquête
vous et d'autres questions mais dieu
travail là ce soir
ouais j'suis désolé on dise mon écoute
excusez moi mais je n'avais pas le temps
là faut je passe voir mon cousin semble
tu m'as dit tout ce que tu es là médias
si un ça va
j'arrête là j'ai tout arrêté d'accord je
vais arrêter avec ces ordonnances au
mont athos star est maintenant aussi
qu'il va venir ici vote et financer ma
pharmacie tu vas pas fait de fentanyl
non je fais pas le fentanyl on m'a dit
subutex cantonniers non je n'ai pas de
photos ni de la situer vers le fond du
territoire
d'accord je vais faire ça juste pendant
deux mois ça fait six mois que ça dure
je sais mieux lutter
je tout arrêter oki dimitri et 6 passes
tu t'es nous rien ne les arrête de dire
que c'est rien
[Musique]